hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta emisión nos
acompaña camila sosa villada ella es
escritora actriz y dramaturga argentina
autora de varios libros algunos de ellos
son por ejemplo la novia de sandro el
viaje inútil tesis sobre una
domesticación y también las malas una
escritura muy poderosa que emergió con
muchísima fuerza en la escena literaria
su novela a las malas ha sido como una
suerte de revolución literaria así
cuenta la historia de camila una
jovencísima travesti que un día se asoma
al parque sarmiento en la ciudad de
córdoba donde las travestis que ejercían
el trabajo sexual practicaban así su
trabajo y en la historia de las
múltiples violencias que las atraviesan
y también la crueldad que la rodea pero
no sólo eso porque en el parque que
camila eligió porque siempre tuvo
afinidad por los árboles que crecen sin
ayuda de nadie según ella misma cuenta
allí ella encontró un grupo de amigas de
esas que son familia y le dan el amparo
y la protección que tantas veces les fue
negado camila sosa villada
gracias por estos minutos comprados 24
un placer dialogar contigo bueno gracias
por favor gracias a vos camila bueno voy
a comenzar con una cita tuya
el lenguaje es mío es mi derecho me
corresponde una parte de él vino a mí yo
no lo busqué por lo tanto es mío me lo
heredó mi madre lo despilfarró mismo
padre voy a destruir lo dijiste voy a
enfermar lo a confundirlo a incomodar lo
voy a despedazar lo y hacerlo renacer
tantas veces como sean necesarias un
renacimiento por cada cosa bien hecha en
este mundo es todo lo de decir lo
escribiste mejor dicho en las malas este
lenguaje el territorio que no les han
podido arrebatar a las travestis camila
no bueno no se lo puede arrebatar a
nadie
lo cierto es que
lo que sí se puede hacer es
imponer un lenguaje
el lenguaje televisivo el lenguaje
periodístico el lenguaje utilitario es
decir el lenguaje que no se utiliza como
una obra de arte ni como un juego
ni como un viaje sino como
una moneda de cambio es así puede
imponerse perderse creo que no no todo
van a hacer citas quédate tranquila pero
hay otra muy interesante que tiene en la
que dijiste que tu primer acto oficial
de travestismo no fue salir a la calle
vestida de mujer sino que tu primer acto
de travestismo fue a través de la
escritura no fue así que fuiste creando
te y que volvió a crear en vos cómo fue
esa fuerza de creación de vos misma
a fuerza de relatos y no de ropa de
mujer o de maquillajes
bueno
es literal en verdad primero empecé a
escribir como mujer
escribía en primera persona como si
fuera una mujer y después
salía a la calle vestida de mujer
o sea que bueno primero fuiste por
digamos que en la literatura fue donde
te sentiste mujer digamos primero así y
luego lo trasladas te a la calle una
experiencia y en verdad no sé cómo se
siente una mujer tampoco es decir eso
tiene que ver con el lenguaje eso sí
tiene que ver con una imposición que
hubo hasta
en estos últimos años
respecto a nuestra identidad yo la
verdad que
siendo chica y siendo una criatura no me
preguntaba mucho solo
era capaz de hacer cosas es decir
encerrarme en un baño y pintarme la boca
y ponerme
una sábana como si fuera un vestido
pero nunca
pensé que podía estar sintiendo como una
mujer
eso me lo dijeron desde afuera y en
algún momento a mí me sirvió claro para
interpretar me para
explicar a los demás
algo de mí pero que ya ha quedado
vetusto verdad que ya ha quedado un poco
un poco viejo decir eso
lo cierto es
que hablando de identidad es
bueno lo primero que hice fue escribir
como mujer escribía una novela en la que
yo me
usaba con un alter ego de una chica que
iba a la secundaria y se enamoraba de un
profesor bueno hacia eso
ahora hay dos elementos caminos que son
claves en las malas un libro que tengo
en mis manos que aprovecho para
recomendar porque es absolutamente
recomendable esta lectura hablamos de la
furia y la fiesta a travesti no hay
sufrimiento de violencias de todo tipo
pero hay también un goce no un goce de
la vida y fiesta hay celebración de
hecho hay uno de los personajes que dice
que ser travesti es como digamos una
fiesta dos dimensiones que atraviesan
fuertemente el ser travesti verdad
si en verdad ese es son palabras de juan
forn yo la estoy tratando de responder a
ver qué será la furia y la fiesta de ser
travesti
hay un personaje de las malas que dicen
ser travesti en una fiesta bueno es algo
es un recurso es algo
literario que use para este personaje
verdad siento que si conocieran a las
travestis furiosas
se asustarían de hecho
durante muchísimo tiempo gozamos
de la fama de ser violentas
d
responder con muchísima violencia a
determinadas agresiones me parece una
rabia justicia una rabia necesaria
además y que hay que conservar como si
eso fuera un tesoro como si eso fuera
algo que verdaderamente tenemos que
defender porque es de las cosas más
auténticas que hay en una sociedad tan
anestesiada y que vive la servidumbre
así con una resignación tan grande
eso claro es una rabia muy estigmatizada
y que sin embargo puede ser el motor
para muchísimos cambios transformaciones
positivas
camila te quería proponer hablar ahora
del amor no esa experiencia que se le
niega a muchísimas travestis no hablamos
de ser amadas a plena luz del día no que
reconozcan que las aman en las malas
están estos personajes que son los
hombres expatriados no los hombres sin
cabeza como les llamamos en el libro que
las aman de manera absolutamente abierta
a través de ellos buenos estás hablando
de esta necesidad imperiosa de destrozar
de acabar con los mandatos sociales para
poder de alguna manera amar fuera de lo
que dice la norma
bueno y amar como se llama dentro de la
norma ya es bastante ya está bastante
está bastante sucio el amor que nosotras
y nosotros podemos conocer en este en
este tiempo es decir
[Música]
cuántas mujeres se han casado con
hombres que decían amarla y qué
lo normal era que las engañarán
que las golpearán que no se hicieran
cargo de la crianza de sus hijos
cuántas personas dicen amar y en verdad
lo que quieren es
comerse al otro devorarlo dejarlos sin
amigos sin
privacidad sin tiempo libre y que no
esté dedicados más que a ellas mismas
entonces digo bueno el amor normal como
se lo conoce
es injusto y aberrante para todos
e
[Música]
para las travestis
ha sido un poco difícil yo prefiero
decir que nos deseen abiertamente a
decir que nos amen de ciertamente
más
y también pienso en
los hombres sin cabeza los hombres sin
cabeza son personajes en los que yo puse
qué bonitas imágenes verdad me distraigo
porque estoy viendo estas imágenes que
ponen y me parecen muy bonitas vista de
gracias de graciosa
lo que sí quiero decir es que esos
hombres sin cabeza
tienen cosas buenas de todos los hombres
que yo amén de todos los hombres que me
amaron también claro que fueron muchos
nos queda muy poquito tiempo menos de un
minuto camina pero hace varios años en
una charla que diste hablaste con la
admiración de gabriela nokia embarazada
y en bicicleta del parque y preguntaste
pensaron alguna vez si la poesía podría
tener una forma tan concreta como esa
mujer llegando a trabajar y yéndose en
bici siempre viste la poesía de esa
forma tan concreta perdón pero nos
quedan menos de un minuto te pido
disculpas bueno es un poco que la poesía
es una imagen que se recibe con todo el
cuerpo no así que sí claro que sí y
donde la veías donde la comenzaste a ver
en la pobreza en la pobreza absoluta en
la que vivíamos había
una sensibilidad
enorme una comunicación enorme con el
alrededor es decir con el monte con los
pájaros con los animales con los
animales que crea vamos mi mamá
cocinando mi papá cocinando también
eso
camila sosa villada ha sido realmente un
placer esta entrevista contigo y estos
minutos muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en france 24 en español un
cáncer breve bueno bueno ya nos
volveremos a encontrar y a nuestra
audiencia como siempre la invitamos a
seguir informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y también en france
mit y cuatro.com sigan con nosotros
[Música]